remember we played this wacky tick-tock
video last week
where it was some young person
describing the difference between an
aromantic person
and an asexual person and that these are
different things or something well now
there's another
professor on tick-tock a professor of
tick tock who has come out and said no
they're different but they're actually
they're actually the same and try to
understand it
next up we have ace flux
so ace flux is your person uh they're
going to fluctuate between
asexuality and allosexual so like
uh it's your person that one day they
could be like
fully asexual and then the next it could
totally change
so this is a person whose sexuality is
gonna fluctuate
on a daily basis one day they could have
crushes on somebody
one day they could be sexually attracted
to somebody
in some form or degree and the next day
they could be completely just
not interested not wanting anything to
do with so this is your person that's
going to be
asexual one day in some form or degree
of sexual the next
i think that's really interesting that's
very cool and
i love learning about these things as i
go along so if you know anybody who's on
the ace flux or anything
please tag them let them know share it
like comment thank you so you
first of all this this gal is just
describing everybody it's like yeah
and some days people are more sexually
inclined than others so oh really wow
i guess i'm that special thing now i'm
an ace or allo or whatever but
you might say michael that's just some
sort of wacky tick tock video that's
gone viral
the scientists are backing this stuff up
there was a medical school professor
yesterday we talked about them on the
show
at a prominent medical school in the
university of california system
who apologized to his students for for
saying the phrase pregnant women because
it's suggested that only women can
become pregnant
the kooky tick tock stuff is being
adopted by
the scientists because it's there's
nothing
scientific about it it's just a
heretical religion and anyone can take
part in a heretical religion and these
people don't
they don't even know what they don't
know they don't even know that they're
making
philosophical and religious claims when
they pretend that it's just all about
the natural material world and we can't
question any of that because if we do
we could easily be booted out of the
public square
i'm glad you liked that clip i need you
to do me a favor i need you to head on
over to apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play wherever it gets your
podcasts
and subscribe to the michael knowles
show then leave a star review and stick
it into the eye
of big tech censors who are trying to
tell me what i can and cannot say
i really appreciate it subscribe like it
you know get the book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you